in this last section we'll learn about
bigquery which is Google's fully managed
petabyte scale low-cost analytics data
warehouse
bigquery is a fully managed serverless
data warehouse
a data warehouse is a large store that
contains terabytes and petabytes of data
gathered from a wide range of sources
within an organization and it's used to
guide management decisions
being fully managed means that bigquery
takes care of all the underlying
infrastructure so you can focus on using
SQL queries to answer business questions
without worrying about deployment
scalability and security
let's look at some key features of
bigquery
one
bigquery provides two services in one
storage plus Analytics
it's a place to store petabytes of data
for reference one petabyte is equivalent
to 11 000 movies at 4K quality
bigquery is also a place to analyze data
with built-in features like machine
learning geospatial analysis and
business intelligence which we'll
explore a bit later on
two bigquery is a fully managed
serverless solution which means that you
use SQL queries to answer your
organization's biggest questions in the
front end without worrying about
infrastructure in the back end
if you've never written SQL before don't
worry this course provides resources and
labs to help
three bigquery has a flexible
pay-as-you-go pricing model where you
pay for the number of bytes of data your
query processes and for any permanent
table storage
if you prefer to have a fixed bill each
month you can also subscribe to Flat
Rate pricing where you can have a
reserved amount of resources for use
four
data in bigquery is encrypted at Rest by
default without any action required from
a customer
by encrypted at rest we mean that
encryption is used to protect data that
is stored on a disk including solid
state drives or backup media
and five bigquery has built-in machine
learning features so you can write ml
models directly in bigquery by using SQL
also if you use other professional tools
such as vertex AI from Google Cloud to
train your ml models
you can export data sets from bigquery
directly into vertex AI for a seamless
integration across the data to AI
lifecycle
so what does the typical architecture of
a data warehouse solution look like
the input data can be either real-time
or batch data if it's streaming data
which can be either structured or
unstructured high speed and large volume
Pub sub is needed to digest the data
if it's batch data it can be directly
uploaded to cloud storage
after that both pipelines lead to data
flow to process the data
dataflow is where we extract transform
and load the data if needed
bigquery sits in the middle to link data
processes by using dataflow and data
access through analytics Ai and ml tools
the job of the analytics engine of
bigquery at the end of a data pipeline
is to ingest all the process data after
ETL
store and analyze it and then possibly
output it for further use such as data
visualization and machine learning
bigquery outputs usually feed into two
buckets
business intelligence tools and Ai and
ml tools
if you're a business analyst or data
analyst you can connect to visualization
tools like looker Google data Studio
Tableau or other bi tools
if you prefer to work in spreadsheets
you can query both small or large
bigquery data sets directly from Google
Sheets and even perform common
operations like pivot tables
alternatively if you're a data scientist
or machine learning engineer you can
directly call the data from bigquery
through automl or vertex AI workbench
these Ai and ml tools are part of vertex
AI Google's unified ml platform
bigquery is like a common staging area
for data analytics workloads
when your data is there business
analysts bi developers data scientists
and machine learning Engineers can be
granted access to your data for their
own insights
bigquery can ingest data sets from
various sources including internal data
which is data saved directly in bigquery
external data
bigquery also offers the option to query
external data sources like data stored
and other Google Cloud Storage services
such as cloud storage or in other Google
Cloud database services such as spanner
or Cloud SQL in bypass bigquery manage
storage
this means that our raw CSV file in
cloud storage or a Google sheet can be
used to write a query without being
ingested by bigquery first
multi-cloud data which is data stored in
multiple cloud services such as AWS or
azure
and public data sets if you don't have
data of your own you can analyze any of
the public data sets available in the
cloud Marketplace
after the data is stored in bigquery
it's fully managed and is automatically
replicated backed up and set up to Auto
scale
you can use three basic patterns to load
data into bigquery
the first is a batch load where Source
data is loaded into a bigquery table in
a single batch operation
this can be a one-time operation or it
can be automated to occur on a schedule
a batch load operation can create a new
table or append data into an existing
table
the second is streaming where smaller
batches of data are streamed
continuously so that the data is
available for querying in near real time
and the third is generated data where
SQL statements are used to insert rows
into an existing table or to write the
results of a query to a table
of course the purpose of bigquery is not
to just store data it's for analyzing
data and helping to make business
decisions
bigquery is optimized for running
analytic queries over large data sets it
can perform queries on terabytes of data
in seconds in petabytes in minutes
this performance lets you analyze large
data sets efficiently and get insights
in near real time
Google data Studio looker and many
integrated partner tools can be used to
draw analytics from bigquery and build
sophisticated interactive data
visualizations
bigquery also has built-in capabilities
for building machine learning models
an ml model lets you solve certain kinds
of problems at scale by using data
examples but without the need for custom
code
machine learning and large data sets
requires extensive programming and
knowledge of ml Frameworks
these requirements restrict solution
development to a small set of people
within each company and they exclude
data analysts who understand the data
but have limited machine learning
knowledge and programming expertise
bigquery ml empowers data analysts to
use machine learning through existing
SQL tools and skills
analysts can use bigquery ml to build
and evaluate ml models in bigquery
analysts no longer need to export small
amounts of data to spreadsheets or other
applications and they no longer need to
wait for limited resources from a data
science team
bigquery ml functionality is available
by using the bigquery web UI
the BQ command line tool
the bigquery rest API
and an external tool such as jupyter
notebook or business intelligence
platform